لم يكن الرئيس جو بايدن على علم لعدة أيام
بأن وزير الدفاع لويد أوستن تم
إدخاله إلى المستشفى منذ يوم رأس السنة الجديدة، حيث
أخبر مصدر مطلع على الأمر شبكة
CNN أن مستشار الأمن القومي جيك
سوليفان أطلع الرئيس بايدن على هذه
القضية بعد أن علم هو نفسه بدخول
المستشفى بعد
ظهر يوم الخميس.  لم يكشف البنتاغون علنًا عن دخول
أوستن إلى المستشفى حتى يوم
الجمعة، ثم كشفوا بعد ذلك أنه
دخل مركز والتر ريد الطبي بعد
إجراء طبي اختياري وقد
عانى من بعض المضاعفات، وقد
مكث هناك طوال الأسبوع ولا
يزال هناك في هذا الوقت الآن، وقد
البنتاغون  لم يقدموا الكثير من
المعلومات حول مدى خطورة
الأمر لكنهم قالوا إن نائب
وزير الدفاع كاثلين هيكس
تولى بعض مهام ومسؤوليات
وزير الدفاع أه أثناء وجوده
تولى وزير الدفاع لويد أوستن
مهامه كاملة أه خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
أه لكن وأصدر بيانًا
قال فيه إنه في حالة تحسن
ويتطلع إلى العودة إلى
البنتاغون لكنه تناول بعض
قضايا الشفافية هذه مع عدم
الكشف عن حقيقة وجوده في
المستشفى قبل ذلك بكثير كما كتب في
البيان  وأضاف: "أتفهم أيضًا
مخاوف وسائل الإعلام بشأن الشفافية
وأدرك أنه كان بإمكاني القيام بعمل أفضل
لضمان إعلام الجمهور بشكل مناسب،
وألتزم بالقيام بعمل أفضل
ولكن من المهم أن أقول إن هذا
كان الإجراء الطبي الخاص بي وأتحمل
المسؤولية الكاملة عن ذلك".  وتأتي القرارات المتعلقة
بالكشف الآن عن دخوله المستشفى
في وقت مهم حيث لا تزال الولايات المتحدة
تتصارع مع الحرب الروسية في
أوكرانيا وكذلك الصراع في
الشرق الأوسط بين إسرائيل وحماس،
وهناك أيضًا مخاوف أكبر بشأن
انتشار هذا الصراع وتحوله إلى صراع
إقليمي أوسع.  لا تزال هناك الكثير من
الأسئلة حول السبب الدقيق الذي أرسل
أوستن إلى المستشفى ولماذا
انتظر طويلاً للكشف عن ذلك ليس فقط
للجمهور ولكن للرئيس بايدن، حيث يوقع على
CNN وهو يسافر مع
الرئيس في ويلمنجتون
ديلاوير.